scusi io sono incinta cosa posso
mangiare è congelato è pastorizzato e
decaffeinato ben cotto Mi raccomando non
so se gliel'ho detto ma sono incinta No
guarda io ho zero sintomi né una nausea
un po' di sonnolenza A volte mi chiedo
ma non è che non sono incinta poi guardo
la pancia e mi rasserino E tu invece
stai facendo le penne dell'inferno oh mi
dispiace Quanti chili ha preso per ora
solo 15 Beata te mi sono già 18 ho
trovato più forte di me sempre fame ma
tu dove si perdono no Toglietemi tutto
ma non l'allenamento vediamo quando sono
qui dentro Allora assorbono tutto quindi
ho forza di fare yoga avrò un bambino
che sarà calmo e rilassato Infatti
secondo me farà Zen Matteo Zen
bellissimo vero e quindi mi hanno detto
di non preoccuparmi che non Uh Oddio un
crampo fammi scrivere subito la mia
estetica potrebbe essere qualcosa di
molto grave scusa devo di nuovo andare a
fare la pipì dopo il bagno no non so
com'è possibile mi scappa continuamente
le stesse stregoneria è questa